ihre absicht ist sehr offensichtlich
dass sie gewalt gegen taiwan ausüben
wollen darauf müssen wir vorbereitet
sein
und im hinblick auf die chinesischen
militärübungen in der region und den
ausbau ihrer militärischen fähigkeiten
kommt ein weiterer aspekt hinzu
ein konflikt der aus versehen ausgelöst
wird
zum beispiel wenn china weiter über
taiwans duft verteidigungszone fliegt
oder sich plötzlich zwei armeen
gegenüber stehen
das gilt nicht nur für die straße von
taiwan china macht auch militärübungen
im ostchinesischen und südchinesischen
meer und dort kommt es immer wieder zu
begegnungen mit der japanischen armee
den amerikanern australien oder den
streitkräften anderer länder
ein versehentlicher krieg ist möglich
das müssen wir verhindern damit es nicht
zu einem großen konflikt kommt in den
viele länder innen gezogen werden das
will keiner
hier in den vereinigten staaten scheint
es einen politischen konsens zu geben
dass china taiwan früher oder später
angreifende
entweder weil china weiter nach oben
strebt oder weil es einen niedergang
verhindernde präsident biden bestätigte
ja kürzlich in einem interview die
vereinigten staaten würden taiwan im
fall eines angriffs verteidigen
glauben sie dass der amerikanische
präsident sein wort halten wird
wir zweifeln nicht an amerikas
eindeutigen bekenntnis zur teil warnung
natürlich hoffen wir dass die usa taiwan
auch weiterhin mit waffen in ausbildung
und dienstleistungen versorgt und den
informationsaustausch auf höchster ebene
fliegt damit teil waren in der lage ist
sich selbst zu verteidigen
es liegt in unserer verantwortung
auf unsere eigene verteidigung zu achten
wenn china nach taiwan kommt haben wir
die willenskraft und die manpower um für
unser heimatland zu kämpfen
jeder soll wissen dass sie nicht einfach
in taiwan einmarschieren können nicht
heute und auch nicht morgen oder
nächstes jahr wir wollen unser eigenes
land stärken in china davon abzuhalten
einen krieg gegen taiwan zu beginnen
kürzlich haben sie in interviews davor
gewarnt nicht zu abhängig von china zu
werden deutschland ist ein gutes
beispiel es ist wirtschaftlich sehr eng
mit china verwandelt glauben sie dass
die europäer und speziell die deutsche
regierung in den letzten jahren zu naiv
gegenüber china gewesen sind
es steht mir als außenminister nicht zu
die aussenpolitik eines anderen landes
zu kommentieren insbesondere eines
befreundeten landes
aber angesichts der internationalen lage
hoffen wir dass wir alle aufwachen
[Musik]
die ausbreitung des autoritarismus
findet nicht nur im indopazifik statt
sie üben auch druck auf europa aus
gerade in litauen ist dies zu beobachten
aber nicht nur dort
das ist ein gutes beispiel
china droht der litauischen regierung
weil sie zulässt dass sich ihre
botschaft doch diplomatische vertretung
von taiwan nennt china übt sogar druck
auf deutsche unternehmen aus ihre
wirtschaftlichen verbindungen mit
litauen zu kappen wenn sie weiter mit
china geschäfte machen wollen
der autoritarismus baut seinen einfluss
in taiwan und in anderen ländern
ostasiens immer weiter aus im moment
haben sie litten enel sie üben druck auf
deutschland und deutsche unternehmen aus
wir müssen dem entgegentreten und
maßnahmen ergreifen die verhindern dass
sich der autoritarismus weiter
ausbreitet schließlich glauben wir an
demokratie und freiheit und diese werte
müssen wir verteidigen
wir hoffen dass die europäischen länder
an der seite litauens stehen und beim
widerstand gegen erpressung und
autoritarismus mein ratschlag an unsere
deutschen freunde ist wenn sie glauben
dass ihre wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit
china jetzt schon zu eng sind dann
sollten sie sich klar machen dass china
vielleicht ja auch von deutschen kapital
von deutscher technologie und vom
deutschen markt abhängig ist
wenn es auf prinzipien ankommt müssen
wir klar zu unseren prinzipien stehen
diese auseinandersetzung findet auch
noch einer weiteren ebene statt den
olympischen spielen im hinblick auf die
unterdrückung taktik in der chinesischen
regierung ihren menschen und bürger
rechtsverletzungen hätte es ihrer
meinung nach ein deutlicheres signal der
demokratien geben müssen mehr als nur
einen diplomatischen boykott
wissen sie die bahn ist von allen großen
internationalen organisationen
ausgeschlossen das ist eine sehr
schmerzhafte erfahrung für uns lassen
sie mich ihnen eine kleine geschichte
erzählen als mein sohn sechs jahre alt
war machte ein virus die runde in taiwan
damals waren wir kein mitglied der
weltgesundheitsorganisation nicht mal
ein beobachter wir baten die whu
experten zu schicken um uns zu helfen
aber niemand kam
sie teilten nicht einmal ihre
erfahrungen im umgang mit dem virus und
als folge litten und starben viele
kinder
wir müssen also jede möglichkeit
ergreifen damit taiwan sich an
internationalen angelegenheiten
beteiligen kann
das gilt auch für unsere athleten wir
werden uns sehr bemühen die teilnahme
unserer athleten an den spielen nicht zu
gefährden opportunity to pass
lassen sie mich abschließend fragen was
ist das zwischen china und den usa ist
es nur konkurrenz ist es ein neuer
kalter krieg wie manche leute es nennen
oder es ist tatsächlich mehr ein
gefährliches duell um die weltherrschaft
das uns alle in den nächsten weltkrieg
führen könnte
china kämpft um seine globale dominanz
wenn wir die situation nicht nur aus
heutiger sicht betrachten sondern über
die nächsten 20 30 jahre blicken wird
chinas absicht sehr deutlich
wir sollten das sehr nüchtern betrachten
und müssen uns fragen ob wir zulassen
dass der autoritarismus unser leben
dominiert
und wenn wir das nicht wohnt müssen wir
china ganz ungeschminkt sagen dass die
demokratie nicht tolerieren werden wie
china versucht seinen bösartigen
einfluss auf andere länder auch zu üben
exercises jetzt in vs-obereschach
wir müssen uns gegen seine des
informationskampagnen wären hybride
kognitive kriegsführung seine grauzonen
taktiken
demokratien müssen zusammenstehen um zu
verhindern dass sich der autoritarismus
weiter ausbreitet
minister wo ich danke ihnen herzlich für
das gespräch
[Musik]